here with reaction out kick founder clay
travis along with the co-host of the
five geraldo rivera although i mean
electric cars are fine i once had an
escalade hybrid wasn't too bad by the
way i love the let's go brandon t-shirt
uh clay uh
yeah it was fine
but when you when when you break down
how you charge it when you break down
how you build it when you break down the
cost of it uh it's a fantasy that
they're they're peddling here in the
meantime we're gonna beg iran saudi
arabia and venezuela does that make
sense to you
it doesn't but if president baden could
put together a coherent narrative as you
just did laying it all out i think it
would be in a much better place what he
is trying to say and here i am
translating for the president of the
united states
what he's trying to say
because you know i know and clay travis
knows and this audience knows that he's
weak and he's frail and he's a cognitive
wreck but go ahead you translate for him
but he is the president of the united
states and you know
is a ridiculous idea it is a very
transitory uh you know feel-good fix for
a day or two what we need to do and what
he should do rather than promoting the
future we'll get to the future rather
than promoting a tesla in every garage
what he should be saying is let's
produce more domestic oil ourselves
let's let's get the the supply up that
will reduce the price you know all right
question
oil companies
why why don't we ask middle in texas why
don't we go to oklahoma for natural gas
why don't we go to pennsylvania new york
and ohio why don't we start here and
finish the keystone xl pipeline
and get 900 000 barrels of canadian oil
a day why don't we do that
well listen to my idea the the oil
companies reaping record profits that's
true that is undeniably true but how do
you get them to invest enough so they
can produce more now so we're not
dependent on venezuela and and saudi
arabia and iran and so forth you do it
by telling the the oil companies you
keep your record profits we're not going
to impose a windfall profits tax as the
left is now agitating to do and how do
you keep going
you must produce how did that work out
for jimmy carter clay travis you're a
historian
sean the oil and gas companies don't
want to invest because they know the rug
is going to get pulled out from
underneath their feet by the biden
administration as soon as the midterms
are here they want lower gas prices for
five months they'll say anything that
they think scores them political points
and then as soon as the midterms are
here they're not going to offer them any
support at all because don't miss what's
going on here guys ultimately this is
what the democrats want because the gas
prices need to go up in order for all of
the solar and the wind power and the
electric to get remotely competitive
with gas prices there was a great story
in the wall street journal a
a writer there tried to travel did you
guys see it from new orleans to chicago
and back on an electric vehicle and it
was a disaster she couldn't find
anywhere to charge the charging stations
didn't work and the article ended with
her saying i've never been happier to
pay four dollars and fifty cents a
gallon than have to deal with a long
range trip right now on an electric
vehicle and i wish everybody had sixty
four thousand dollars as you mentioned
geraldo to go out and be able to buy
them but this is the democrat push if
you're troubled by the price of high gas
then go buy an ev geraldo and sean
recently i went to go fill up my car
somebody had spent
4.50 this was several weeks ago for one
gallon of gas probably to be able to get
to and from work to try to make it so
that they could continue to produce for
their family
you might as well tell them that they
should go buy a dragon as go buy an
electric vehicle all right clay horado
that's my point there is an emergency
there is an emergency now let biden
understand the emergencies
he gave up leases on public lands he
killed off keystone xl he stopped anwar
he artificially reduced the supply tell
him to go back to trump's policies
i think you've got to recognize the
exigent circumstance and he's got to be
flexible he's got to be nimble he's got
to be creative
he's none of those things geraldo he can
barely read a teleprompter he can't ride
a bike he's not flexible and nimble and
sophisticated these are not adjectives
that
was a little sensitive because you know
he did once say 70 is the new 50. i have
read that somewhere i don't know what
you don't know that's right i hope he's
right thank you by the way hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else